et on parle à présent Mickaël foot US
avec nos invités qui sont revenus en
plateau et oui c'est l'heure de la
reprise pour les Templiers d'Élancourt
les joueurs qui voulaient au complexe
sportif Europe à Élancourt débute leur
saison de deuxième division ce week-end
sur le terrain des Léopards de Rouen
pour nous en parler nous avons avec nous
sur ce plateau le capitaine Jordan de
brasse et Alix Wemba qui est
coordinateur défense bonsoir Monsieur
parce que je vous ai pas vu
alors comment vous sentez-vous à
quelques jours de la reprise
quelques jours de la reprise pour nous
on a déjà repris depuis longtemps elle a
fait la prépa physique officielle la
reprise officielle bah comme je disais
tout à l'heure on est dans le bain on a
eu deux matchs amicaux c'est plus ou
moins bien passé on finit sur une
victoire on fait un petit match nul voir
comme c'était une opposition d'entente
donc ça va ça s'est bien passé aussi
on est dans le bain on est sur une bonne
dynamique je pense que on attend tous le
championnat enfin du football américain
c'est pour aller au match on a pas le
choix et on est tous impatient c'est
vraiment ce qui c'est vraiment ce qui
nous anime là c'est qu'on a l'impression
de reprendre en tout cas au niveau de la
confiance les voyants sont ovaires sont
au vert mais c'est c'est pas une c'est
pas une conscience en fait c'est pas une
confiance qui est définitive c'est
surtout une envie c'est une pulsion
c'est c'est un besoin en fait c'est
surtout ça vous êtes impatient vous
aussi dans des cours sur le terrain si
je peux dire moi c'est les matchs qui me
c'est les matchs qui me motivent c'est
les matchs qui me qui me pousse et bah
pour en revenir sur notre confiance
et surtout une année où on arrive en
début de championnat sans trop de
blessures on arrive vraiment avec
comment dire un bilan médical qui est
plutôt bon on a très peu de joueurs
blessés des joueurs qui ont joué toute
la saison dernière blessée qui se sont
bien reposés et qui se sont bien soignés
et là on revient en pleine forme avec
une bonne préparation physique j'imagine
c'est ça une bonne préparation physique
on a repris début septembre on a poussé
un petit peu avec les équipes jeunes
parce que on a vraiment accentué sur la
formation c'est cette année donc on est
plutôt pas mal normalement comment vous
trouvez ce groupe le groupe est jeune il
vit bien on a eu quelques arrêts de fin
de carrière l'année dernière
ce groupe a quand même eu quelques
départs de part comme je disais la
formation dans des équipes de division
supérieures de première division donc on
a perdu quelques bons éléments
malheureusement c'est le jeu
heureusement pour nous parce que ça veut
dire qu'on fait du bon travail
malheureusement pour nous on perd des
éléments très importants mais le groupe
il est sain il y a eu un peu de tornover
au niveau de du coachy staff il y a eu
un peu de temps 9 heures au niveau des
joueurs on a quelques arrivées quelques
départs tout ce qui est basique dans le
football américain ils sont les qui sont
les nouveaux éléments est-ce que c'est
ce sont des jeunes des Templiers ce qui
a des import US parce qu'on sait qu'il y
a des joueurs des États-Unis qui peuvent
venir aussi voir renforcer bah par
rapport aux saisons précédentes
c'est vrai que par rapport aux saisons
précédentes on n'avait pas mis l'accès
sur sur les le côté américain ce qu'on
voulait vraiment faire de la formation
et rester en interne maintenant quand on
voit les grosses écuries du championnat
on voit bien l'année dernière tour tous
les imports bah forcément
ça ça fait avancer donc oui il y a une
possibilité que
que on se recroise sur le plateau ou
peut-être ailleurs où je vous présente
quelqu'un qui vient nous aider pour le
championnat et qui intègre l'équipe
peut-être dans les prochaines heures
aussi peut-être Jordan
[Musique]
Michael et midoro regardez qui avait
testé le football américain avec les
Templiers d'Élancourt qui s'est pris un
gros plaquage nickel il y a quelques
années j'avais testé voilà j'aurais pu
jouer peut-être apparemment receveur
peut-être
tant pis est-ce qu'ils ont mis le
plateau ils ont été peut-être sympa avec
vous Michael on va peut-être pleuvoir
alors je me souviens plus du nom du
joueur
plaqué ouais c'est ça
et ça va il va bien ben écoutez comme
disait Jordan tout à l'heure on est très
famille donc du coup les anciens joueurs
certains que vous avez vu dans la vidéo
dont moi qui était présent à l'époque le
jour où il a pris son sacré plaquage bah
en fait on est toujours investi dans le
club donc redis sur peur va très très
bien c'est le directeur sportif
actuellement au club et comme disait
Jordan qui est aussi ancien joueur et
continuer à jouer on est vraiment
présent on essaie de tout donner on
essaie de continuer à perdurer faire pas
monter le club petit à petit cette
saison qui sera l'extérieur qui sera le
8e prochain face au léopard de Rouen
comment vous l'aborder cette rencontre
c'est du foot américain donc nous on
arrive sur le terrain toujours avec un
esprit de vainqueur on peut pas arriver
sur le terrain en se disant voilà on va
peut-être perdre le match c'est pas du
foot normal c'est pas du soccer où on se
dit il faut qu'on essaie de pas perdre
on arrive en disant on va gagner tout
simplement donc on aura toujours
l'objectif de gagner toujours l'envie de
gagner et après ce sera match après
match qu'on verra qu'on verra comment ça
se passe mais en tout cas l'objectif le
premier objectif c'est de gagner le
premier match c'est ça et en plus pour
le comme le dit Jordan quand on aborde
l'état d'esprit quand on aborde un match
comme ça qui est le premier de la saison
on se retrouve à l'extérieur qu'on a pas
le public on n'est pas chez nous comme
on dit il faut arriver avec cette esprit
cette envie de gagner bien sûr après le
c'est le terrain qui parle le score
final nous dira si c'est le bon état
d'esprit ou pas mais il faut avoir cette
envie c'est envie est présente et on est
obligé d'y aller de cette manière
justement vous allez attendre ses
proches pour rétablir peut-être
l'objectif de la saison vous êtes en
deuxième division depuis 2017 la
deuxième division depuis 2017 comme vous
l'avez bien vu bah il y a un certain
laps de temps de formation
moi qui ai joué à l'époque dans les dans
dans les équipes seniors et dans les
hautes équipes de
vision et autres là on est sur une phase
de construction on est sur une phase de
recrutection en fait qui prend son temps
et elle est pérenne elle est pérenne
puisqu'on arrive à rester justement dans
cette deuxième division on accède
régulièrement en face de playoff et je
pense que cet objectif doit être en
continu l'accession playoff et après
viser toujours plus haut l'année
dernière c'est ce qui nous est arrivé on
nous fait un bon parcours malgré 7 ou 8
blessés en un match qui nous a un peu
mal mis on finit par battre notre
concurrent direct qui est le repas de
Rouen qu'on recroise ce weekend et on
perd en playoff face au championnat 2e
division je pense que c'est un parcours
qu'on peut atteindre encore cette année
en tout cas on doit tendre à
allez dans cette direction vous faites
partie favoris
favoris comment on dirait quand vous
avez quand vous êtes en deuxième
division et que vous êtes installé et
qu'une équipe des 100 premières division
est-ce qu'il fait partie des favoris
d'accord pareil moi je vous montrerai la
même chose je peux vous dire qu'on est
une bonne équipe de 2e division et c'est
le terrain qui parlera ça c'est sûr et
le 28 ça sera le premier match de la
saison à domicile ça sera contre les
caïmans du Mans pareil vous allez offrir
un beau spectacle vous supporter vous
espérons en tout cas on espère offrir un
peu ce que tu es supporter pareil le
calmement du mot qui monte au troisième
division il me semble champion champion
voilà champion de Détroit donc ils
arrivent avec les dents longues ça c'est
sûr mais qui va prendre au sérieux une
équipe à prendre au sérieux ils sont
bien construits ils ont mis le temps à
monter quand et là je pense qu'ils vont
arriver en fait plein de plein de bonnes
volonté et pareil on les accueillera de
la même façon avec l'envie de gagner
dernière question rapidement un mot pour
vous adversaires qui vous regarde
sûrement à la télévision en ce moment
bah les adversaires on arrive
on arrive protégez-vous tout simplement
merci à vous deux en tout cas d'être
passé en Platon vous souhaite une très
bonne saison une très bonne saison à
2023 de foot US